any questions speed fire all right top
three anime yeah it was i was gonna we
got to talk about i don't know
one of your favorite anime is because
you said it on my video you're like
parasite right mm-hmm yeah like oh
you're like parasites
i [ __ ] love that show though yeah
yeah so parasite it's like
you know it's like core memory growing
up and watching that and just falling in
love with that one i love when he he
lets miggy take over his heart and he
just becomes a [ __ ] chad and then
he's when you see the before his hair
spikes up he [ __ ] he has sex right
away and it's like this is the greatest
show ever
um again character yeah okay what else
um
i'm really bad with this kind of thing
because i don't usually rank things like
if you say your favorite movie your
favorite tv show
it's just it's easy to have yeah i know
yeah is there any like personal
favorites that you just want to shout
out just reword the questions yeah yeah
because i mean it matters to me because
like when someone says yeah okay what's
your top three okay just tell us your
favorites yeah i like all the normal
ones i mean
you mean like shonen jump like demon
slayer jiu-jitsu trying to piss people
off right now i really know i really
wanted to say like a hentai as a joke
but i couldn't think of
you know the normal anime is like yeah
cow girls
people
i can imagine
um
obviously i love death note growing up i
probably watched that like twice yeah i
watched that on toaster stream
[Music]
i never watched naruto or one i've never
watched them
yeah yeah yeah yeah but one piece is
worth
i hear that
but like i only have one lifetime yeah
yeah why would you not spend that
lifetime watching one piece
do you like a character development you
should watch a show called backy
oh yeah you should watch parky that's
one we advocate for yeah
it's like the uglish [ __ ] thing it's
like these extremely muscular dudes just
fighting each other and it's but this
growth this growth there
i've been enjoying spike's family
obviously of course i also enjoy food
yes right yeah
like demons everybody likes those
growing up i
like fell in love with attack on titan i
was like 14 yeah in morocco in africa
downtown all the episodes i forget how i
have no interest i know
so now 27 i'm so mad
because like if you had just fed me
properly throughout the years i'd still
be happy today but i feel like attack on
titan did not do that have you did it
with it
no that's why i'm like you lost me
throughout the years but i loved you so
much initially it was so good so good
now it's gotten better it gets better
watching it yeah honestly
yeah it's still going
one more final season
well so so there's there's a 2013 right
so nine years yeah 2013.
yeah it came out twenty thousand as
young as yeah yeah
it must be like 15 16.
yeah that probably lines up yeah i think
it came out like the original attack
attack on titan came out 2013 13. yeah
so it's been it's been nine years my
favorite thing about anime and you could
probably understand with parasite a
little bit
an attack on titan is just when it looks
so
[ __ ] up
in a way that would never exist in
humanity like these massive titans with
these jumps oh yeah oh yeah borderline
disgusting smiles yeah like
i guess the closest word to it would be
gore but it doesn't have to be bloody
it's just
freaky yeah um and just how much i guess
how much more possibility there is
within anime i mean i guess cgi is
really advanced now but
it just like that's why every live
action anime fails because you take the
animated aesthetic and you put it to
live action it never works out yeah
it never works out so yeah that's why i
initially like i loved attack on titan
so much and i think just because
i didn't keep up with it throughout the
years yeah but not now i'm gonna finish
it and maybe i'll start now's the
perfect time because you could just
marathon it now we had to wait like
[ __ ] like i can't remember how many
years we had to wait for season two and
i think it was like three or four years
yeah yeah
exactly yeah that's why i will happily
marathon i think i watch season two um
like folks
uh we're on season four now no we're on
we're on a season we just finished
season three no the final season part
two yeah yeah and then it was the final
season part one but it isn't the final
season because there is another final
season that's coming out which is the
final season the final
season three part one and then there was
season three part two yeah and now we're
on the final season yeah then
i still think there's going to be a
movie
[Music]
i'm bidding yeah
season 3 is like the most hyped season
yeah season 3 is [ __ ] insane you will
lose your [ __ ] that's after the basement
no no
wait you don't you know what's in the
basement i want or like i remember
talking about it with some friends so i
want to say maybe
no you know if you've seen the hype
[ __ ]
it's burned into my memory yeah okay so
you guys don't care about spoilers and
stuff uh spoiler alert spoiler warning
for attack on titles
so
because i watch certain parts of it
throughout the years it's almost hard to
remember i remember i watched the
initial setup the first season yeah yeah
and then a little bit more of them kind
of fighting then you find out oh my god
this person is a titan too yeah
this person is a titan yeah oh my god
this oh my god that right yeah and then
something about the basement and then
the storyline just lost me
okay so you didn't get to the base yeah
yeah guaranteed like the basement
yeah they probably talked about it a
little bit initially but i don't think
you actually got to the basement they
don't get into it until some later it's
like season three right then yeah final
season yeah yeah yeah because those
finals yeah no no they don't get to the
basement until literally the last two
episodes of season three where they
explain everything and it's worth it
it's one of the few it's one of the few
shows
i'm thinking about
it's one of the few shows that builds up
this massive event and then delivers
yeah
it's kind of really slow and then season
three initially is it not about titans
yeah so it's really it gets very like
political you're like what the [ __ ] but
then it all makes sense you're like ah
this is amazing yeah yeah it was very
high it's worth it so yeah watch second
time
it is worth the hype yeah it is it is
the mainstream anime that i think is
just genuinely worth all this like all
the reputation that it has yeah yeah
absolutely
yeah so sometimes i feel kind of bad
talking about anime because
i feel like
people are like you watch anime
casually fake faces
there's a lot of emotions in there yeah
yeah but for me legit it's like i've
been watching since i was young it's
just like i'll just watch
yeah that's fine um like promise
neverland was great oh season well
season one season one we don't don't we
don't talk about season two yeah
yeah so um there's this one that i can't
remember it's it's new it's on netflix
it's about this little boy who lives
alone
oh
that one oh
okay so cute why you watched that i
watched like a few episodes oh wow see
that's how you know casual views yeah
yeah yeah you're on netflix and you're
like i'll just watch the first thing
that comes together but it's good it's
just so cute
i'm not going to be like you should
really watch it because the storyline
the character but it's just like you
watch it right whatever that's just like
slice of life anime in general yeah yeah
it's hard enough finding anime that you
enjoy watching so if you can get
enjoyment out of a show who the [ __ ]
gives a [ __ ] yeah
also watch sword art online probably
like all the really popular ones yeah i
tried to watch re zero and i couldn't
any do you guys think all right zero
three zero zero
[Applause]
yeah when you [ __ ] said that dude
it's like reply zero zero
i watched like the first um
like two or three episodes and for some
reason
i could not watch someone do the same
thing over and over again just to like
get it right like i yeah that was
tilting me but i heard it's great so i'm
not gonna say it's bad yeah they
actually stop doing that kind of they
don't do that as much yeah actually the
first three episodes i'd say are
probably like maybe some of the weakest
parts of the show this season that's
probably why i didn't finish it yeah i
mean like i'm a three episode andy if
i'm hooked the episodes and i'm watching
the whole thing right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly
if you like think about
that if you didn't like in the first
three episodes you're not gonna like the
series it's probably not gonna work
[Music]
i love rem so much
everyone loves ram i'm i'm so normally i
love wrestling it's so it's it's like
liking vanilla you know whenever you go
to crane games in japan there's always
ram figures yeah she's she's like the
most popular girl i still see her
everywhere that's why i'm like i don't i
do not hate the anime by the way i just
did not finish it like i knew his videos
when i saw rem in round one here on the
crane game damn rem's got an
international now yeah she's always been
i'm pretty sure that's true that's true
if you could pick one anime that you
could watch on stream no worry about you
that's a copyright what would it be
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a great
question that's a really great question
loki i might go back say avatar
oh
i mean is avatar not just like a great
i haven't watched that avatar before
i
only recently watched avatar because i
didn't grow up with nickelodeon yeah
it's [ __ ] awesome isn't it it's
absolutely i can totally see why the
comparison of this is an anime and this
is not an anime please because it you
know technically speaking it's not an
anime but like it certainly gives the
feeling of like a really [ __ ] good
show
yeah yeah it does
um but if you're asking me like to
stream yeah i gotta think like a content
creator oh oh okay
i was about to say if i could choose it
would be one piece because it's
literally endless hours of content or
maybe yeah [ __ ] on titan because like yo
could you imagine like the reactions to
the the twists and the two
and there's like insane fight scenes i
think it's a little i think it would
probably drive more viewership than like
uh
avatar is a little bit slower at times
when you're a whole summer about this
story which again storyline with streams
yeah you know as much as i i i'm like i
don't think reaction video is like the
best stuff
you know you sometimes you want to watch
people's reactions to like the fights
the people who react way too hard to
things
oh my god they start [ __ ] freaking
out
that's why that's why etiquette was such
a thing right yeah like everything he
reacted to was either wholesome or just
like he was so [ __ ] yeah like he was
more of the entertainment than the thing
he wanted yeah exactly exactly that's
why it's hard to say reaction content
bad or reaction content good like
there's a lot it's a spectrum see i'm an
awful reactor like
i remember like that yeah
yeah yeah i just i just i just like have
commentary on my mind and sometimes it's
just like she's like the light this is
the linus retirement face yeah yeah yeah
i don't react to [ __ ] while i watch it i
react to it like afterwards
i have to pause yeah i have to pull
people pissed off like [ __ ] pause
but then sometimes i try to commentate
as i'm going along and he's like can you
just pause yeah yeah just every 10
seconds actually uh
actually this reminds me
speaking of crap oh my god it's like
so many things
for me i think that's part of the
streamer lifestyle you know yeah but
also when people ask me about react
content i'm not here to be like this is
my opinion and what is right
the way what i think is like i cannot
wait for surely the day whether it's in
2 5 10 20 years when co-watching things
sort of kind of starting to try and do
it but it's not bad too much like
copyright and limitations if that was um
if that was like allowed that would be
the next meta 100
because being able to like
watch something with someone who's
watching it yeah with the reactions of
tens of thousands of people at once like
there's just a there's no it's an
unparalleled experience yeah i don't
know i totally agree i would if i could
i'd love to yeah
i mean we've been trying to convince
japanese companies for like yeah yeah
yeah you're not the only one